yo what's going on guys crispy flakes
here all bleach report we just had one
of the craziest nba trade deadlines of
all time like so much just call me off
guard and for today's video we are
checking out grading every deal at the
2022 nba trade deadline uh by dan here
and basically we're gonna go through the
grades i'm gonna give you guys my grades
you know a quick recap of the trade that
went down and uh we're gonna see how my
grade actually compares to the bleacher
report grades also now if you want to go
in the comment section below man like
give me your favorite trade or your
favorite team if they made a trade um
and let me know what you grade it um or
also if your team didn't make a trade uh
let me hear about that in the comment
section below too i'm looking at you
laker fans because you know thc kendrick
none and 2027 first round pick was being
advertised that it was gonna get you
like jeremy grant um i think the lakers
have done something but it sounds like
they're gonna do some out stuff so yeah
we'll uh see how that all goes as the
days go on but this man right here james
harden that's the big one uh and that's
the first trade we are going with here
is james harden to philadelphia ben
simmons to brooklyn okay so the trade
the entire trade right here
ben simmons seth curry andre drummond
and a first round pick uh another first
round pick and two seconds
for i'm sorry they become two seconds
not conveyed for james harden and paul
millsap so i saw this trade right here
man and for the philadelphia 76ers i
gotta give it a name and i gotta give it
an a and the reason i say that is
because ben simmons was not playing the
season he was not playing at all uh seth
curry's good i like seth curry he's a
good shooter and everything like that um
and you know andre drummond was a backup
center so essentially you are you know
you need to get a new backup center
that's easy to do um i guess you got
paul millsap though so it's not really a
center but yeah uh but essentially you
were playing seth kurt with james harden
like with how the lineup stands you
replace seth curry with james harden
to me philadelphia i mean
man i gotta say like
first like that's like my first team i
have an eastern conference now man i
feel like they're gonna be that good
like that duo always gonna be sick with
him in mb i love it um and then from the
nets standpoint i am going to give it
it was okay the the trade itself
i'm gonna give it a b plus and the
reason i'm gonna give it a b plus is
because you know james harden was the
best player out of all these guys um you
know you have ben simmons on the team
you guys see how he's incorporated into
the squad uh hopefully no awkwardness
between him and blake griffin um but
also you know you add on the three-point
shot of seth curry so you know you get
the ben simmons who can't really shoot
but you get the dlc of seth curry that's
nice um i actually think andre drummond
is like loki a really nice solid pickup
because his contract's great and uh this
next team did need some more you know
just kind of like rebounding and length
type of guys to it but obviously when it
comes down to it you know we got to see
how ben simmons meshes with kyrie irving
and kevin durant um you know kyrie's
only eligible to play like 10 games for
the rest of the season in the regular
season kevin durant's going to get
healthy but the trade itself um i think
you know train james harden getting some
additional depth like that and still
getting a great player who's great for
different reasons than ben simmons it
was nice it was definitely nice man but
uh okay let's move on to the next one we
have i guess you have the two grades by
bluetooth report here um they gave b to
the nets
and we got a b plus to the sixers
okay next up we got torrey craig to
phoenix for jalen smith to indiana okay
man so
i initially saw this trade and
i laughed really hard i was like what is
phoenix doing i feel like jalen smith he
hasn't really proven much yet but i
still think the potential is there where
they could have got something good back
for him um
and that's not to say tory craig's a bad
player it's just that when it comes down
to with tory craig it's like yeah he was
on the team last year and everything
like that but jalen smith like 21 year
old who's you know was like a lottery
pick and all that i just feel like
that's worth more than tory craig but
craig should help out the team a little
bit if i had to say it though for the
indiana pacers for a team that's
rebuilding to literally get jalen smith
i believe also yeah let's look at the
full trade here um yeah also getting a
second round pick out of it uh the
pacers
a plus to me that's an a plus trade you
get a guy that has a chance to do
something tory craig wasn't doing much
for the pacers like perfect for a
rebuild um for the suns
honestly i'm to give it a d plus
just because i feel like they could have
gotten so much better for tory craig in
my opinion or for jalen smith in my
opinion man so yeah we got a minus uh
for the bleacher report grade and we got
b
for the sundry okay so i mean
i know i understand like what craig does
and everything my name is craig so
that's bonus not really but for me i
don't know man okay
they could've got something a little bit
better but jalen was unproven so i get
it uh next up we got pj dozier bubble
tour orlando someone got much to say
about this one right here this is more
so a financial type of trade uh bubbles
out for the season so he's not doing
much for the magic so i don't really
have personal grades for this one or
really much to even say about it so
celtics b
plus magic with an a um i'm gonna take
the word on that right there man so yeah
next up derek white to boston josh
richardson to the san antonio spurs okay
so they have the straight up trade here
celtics again derek white josh
richardson romeo and a first round pick
top four protecting to the spurs um for
the celtics i'm gonna give this one
i actually like the bleacher report
great of a b i think that makes a lot of
sense derek white is a 15.5 rebound five
assists type of guy should be able to
play like you know the combo gardeness
and the bad core is marcus smart now
that shooter is no longer on the team
which i'm sure we'll get to later here
um i like him as like you know third
fourth option under uh you know jalen
brown jason tatum marcus smart depending
on what the options like there and then
for the spurs romeo langford is a
rebuild piece you get a pick out of it
drive purchases an expiring deal free
ups my uh some financial flexibility by
not having weight on the team anymore i
think it's not like a four year deal so
yeah for the spurs
um
also a b b plus nothing like huge
crazily here but uh you know you got
some good stuff back for it so not bad
uh next up we have goran dragic out
thaddeus young in for the toronto
raptors so yes it's goron
first round pick um fourth thaddeus
young and drew eubanks in 2022 so
uh it did turn out that
goron was bought out by the spurs so
essentially what happens is the raptors
you know get thaddeus young and the
spurs could have just bought out teddy's
song and that could have been the end of
it but they got a draft pick out of it
so i mean when you get that uh they got
something as opposed to just buying out
that he's young they buy out gore and
get a pick out of it man so obviously
for that reason uh for what they plan on
doing like that's an a like they got a
draft pick out of a guy that was just
going to get bought out anyway um for
the raptors
thaddeus is a good veteran player drew
eubanks athletic type of center
uh my thing with it though is that you
know the team having scottie barnes
pascal ken burch chris boucher og like
that's five forward slash centers as is
i'm curious how thaddeus fits in with
the team uh i feel like he would have
been served you know more serviceable
and more helpful on like a team like the
bulls or somebody like that but
uh they didn't really give up much i
mean i guess they did give a pic in it
so
i think for that
i gotta give it like a b minus c plus
just cause they did give up the pick
they got a second round back out of it
man but i just don't know if daddy's was
like they needed him there you know so
we got an a for the spurs
you have great stuff in the b plus for
the raptors i just think from a depth
standpoint like
there's only so many minutes to be had
around but if he it was a part of the
rotation could be a w
uh here we go here we go here we go man
marvin bagley to detroit searching back
in milwaukee in a four-team trade so
pistons get marvin bagley
clippers get ronnie hood semi-legilay
milwaukee bucks get sergey baka 202 uh
two second round pick and the kings get
down dante vincenzo josh x and trey
lyles so i can talk about marvin bagley
all day i'm not going to because you
know this is about all the teams here
but as a piston fan i was so happy we
gave up josh jackson and trey lyles and
we got a former number two pick yes i
understand there's a stigma that he's a
bust also i realized he was in a bad
situation on the kings had some injury
seasons and uh the fact of the matter
man he's 22 years of age huge w for the
pistons i love it i'm giving it an a i
think it's so low risk high reward
got to give it an amen clippers uh
getting ronnie who to semi always delay
i mean ronnie hood could be like a
decent scorer i guess
not much of a of a needle mover um i'm
not really sure how much either one of
these guys will even play so i'm just
going to give it like a c for average
you know it's not bad it's not great
whatever
uh milwaukee bucks um i actually really
like surgery back on this team you know
they had demarcus cousins for a bit and
i was kind of questioned why they got
rid of him but uh sergey baka is a guy
that can knock down you know three-point
shot play some defense very similar to
how brook lopez plays in that regards so
uh with brick lopez injury we're always
this season you get some insurance
getting sergey bach you still bobby
ports on the team for some more center
depth anyway um
really
they they they they don't have down to
divincenzo anymore but i mean
i feel like surge is kind of what the
team needed more especially already
having uh you know pat connaughton and
grace and allen on the team like they
were okay with that shooting guard spot
anyway uh i like it man um dante's a
good player so i can't give him like an
a for that reason but
like a solid b i'm gonna give a solid b
for the bucks on it and then for the
kings getting dante josh jackson and
trey lyles uh to me
that's
that's a b plus a maybe an a minus we'll
go no no we're actually with an a we're
gonna go to a on this and the reason i
say that is because they literally only
gave up marvin bagley who
was probably more of a chemistry issue
with the team anyway they got a quality
starter and dante perfect with what this
team needed josh x and trey lyles two
really good serviceable players so we
got from bleacher report b minus grade b
grade a minus for the bucks
and a with the kings
um okay okay yeah man yeah i'm trying to
like do my grades first so i don't get
like uh
like persuaded to switch it up based off
the grade here so hopefully that's fun
for you guys to watch and everything all
right next up uh we got uh straight that
happened you know yesterday or a few
days ago uh some bonus to sacramento
tyrese halliburton indiana so yeah
straight up when it comes down to this
um
i thought about it and i mean
i feel like sabonis
i'm gonna give it
i'm gonna give it a
i'm catering between a d plus and a c
minus and i know a lot of people want to
say f but it's hard for me to give an f
because bonus is an all-star player man
like it could have been worse okay like
it could have been a worse haul we were
so shocked that tyreese got traded um
but it could have been for a worse haul
man it could have been a power saw kwame
brown situation right so you got to give
it a little grade just because you did
get an all-star caliber player back just
because the trade wasn't good from a
rebuild standpoint that doesn't take
away from the players the bonuses so i'm
gonna go c minus and i'm gonna go d plus
i'm gonna go d plus um a plus plus plus
plus in indiana man like a future just
superstar tyrese you know a foundation
for the rebuild
okay uh next up we have
norman powell to the clipper so we've
seen him a little bit right here already
this is uh you know roko norman powell
for eric bledsoe keon johnson
i'm gonna just go ahead and give an a
for both teams on this one and the
reason that i say that is because
portland they are in a sell assets mode
to gain financial flexibility that's
what this trade did for them and for the
clippers they got a guy that could be a
third or fourth scoring option or power
but also get roko out of it too who is
always a better like wing defender
two-way player in the nba
uh and then for yeah we got a great for
the clippers yeah i think it made sense
d for the blazers i think from a
financial flexibility standpoint that's
why they did it plus it puts them in a
tank mode now too even quicker uh cj
mccollum to the new orleans pelicans so
yeah this was cj larry dan's tony snell
for nikhil alexander walker josh hart um
and some other dudes so
yeah for the pelicans for what they gave
up i'm going to give this one
an a minus cj doesn't really fit
the
total time frame of ingram and zion but
in the moment it's really nice long term
you know we'll see uh larry nance you're
getting him is actually a low-key nice
pick up too tony smell hasn't been
missed a free throw in three seasons so
that's just a little tony snow fact and
then for portland i mean we know at this
point alexander has been traded away and
everything like that um
i'm gonna give an incomplete grade for
the portland trail blazers just because
like it's really hard to
really access what they're doing if we
know that they are trying to freak as
much money as possible so
we got b plus for the pelicans and a
minus four the blazers uh charis lever
to cleveland love this for cleveland
absolutely love it so this was the trade
ricky rubio who's out for the season
after charis laver some picks were
swapped around too a plus for the
cleveland cavaliers man like this was
just like the nice
good veteran player move to make
for a team that's struggled so much with
injuries but it's still proven to be so
great this season man and then for the
pacers oh they gotta pick for lever they
got out of this contract
good for a rebuild man hey i have no
issues with it whatsoever they got a
good pick for karis levert should be
nice
so uh b plus for the cavaliers
a plus for the pacers and then we got a
three team trade here um yeah this one i
don't really have too much to say about
if i'm being quite honest um portland
free enough money spurs getting some
picks utah jazz get alexander walker
good combo guard who i actually think
will be mentored very nicely by um
jordan clarkson so
uh
yeah we'll look at the degrades here c
for the blazers a for the spurs b plus
for the jazz
i'll uh i'm good with that no issues
there and then we got casio pilot to the
okc thunder um so this is going to be a
second round pick here for casio paula
so i thought this was like setting up
for the heat to free up a roster space
to do something else doesn't appear so
to be where uh you know casey apollo
hopefully gets a good chance maybe shine
a little bit
for the okc thunder so
uh we got a c plus grade here and a for
the thunder i really do like it for the
thunder a lot let's hit it with a
refresh real quick here to make sure
there's no other trades that we've
missed if it was updated while we were
doing this
um so it was 12 out of 12. okay so we
got a few more trades
to uh oh yes yes yes yes yes oh oh
oh we would have almost forget about
this one man porzingis to washington
for din witty to dallas man okay oh boy
yes i'm so hype i didn't forget about
this
didn't woody dallas bertons wizards get
christopher's presents man i'm giving an
f minus minus minus minus
minus minus
to the mavericks on this din witty is
shooting atrociously this season he's a
guy
that is not going to fit nicely
next to
luca in my opinion that team already has
jalen brunson they got gordon dragic in
the buy-out market
they don't need dinwiddie
his contract is like two or three
seasons so you don't get financial
flexibility you take on davis bertons
who's only good thing about him is that
he shoots threes and makes threes but
this season he's really he's barely
doing that he's averaging like six
points per game i think he's shooting
very mid from the three-point line this
season his contract's horrible
um for the wizards a plus plus plus plus
man like no way i'm gonna give an a
minus and the reason i say a minus is
because poor zingers does have the whole
like injury factor to one word yeah
things could happen his contracts got
like two or three years left on it on
like 33 mil a season
but it does actually show bradley beal
that the wizards are doing some things
here and plus veal doesn't really like
um dinwiddie so from a chemistry
standpoint you know addition by
subtraction right there man but i do not
really know what the mavericks were
thinking with this one i feel like there
could have been something something
better out there and was there any other
trades that we missed here
i think that pretty much covers them all
um there we go there we go marvin bagley
one more quick scroll here man but i
think we pretty much covered it all cj
we did that here's levert
all right man
and okay we got other trades okay
perfect so other trades here that we can
just kind of quickly go through
daniel teice for dennis schroeder i
imagine schroeder gets bought out like
don't imagine why he would be on the
rockets unless they're giving up on the
kevin porter at point guard thing i
suppose
so we got a cb minus there we got
montrez to the hornets i think that was
i mean it says b for the hornets b plus
for the wizards
like the hornets got a guy that they
wanted you know a few seasons ago that
they were willing to give a large amount
of money to they get them they get
mantras on what is it like eight million
dollars a season that's great the
wizards
i mean they did i guess vernon carries a
20 year old center that maybe you give
him a chance there is smith gives them
another pointer that's been on the team
before with uh dinwiddie being gone but
once again you feel like there could
have been something better they could
have got from mantras who is still a
pretty solid backhand center in the nba
so one of the best backup centers in the
nba and we got uh aaron holiday to the
wizards for we don't really know yet so
we're gonna incomplete right there man
but that's all we have for this video
hopefully that recaps things pretty
nicely for you guys uh thank you all so
much for watching and peace out my
friends